today i will would be presenting
a novel lc msms method
with dual electro spray and apci iron
source for
analysis of 66 pesticides
regulated by california state in hemp
when i was developing this method i
faced a lot of challenges most lc msms
systems have
only electrospray iron source in them
and some of the pesticides on
california lists such as
pentachloronitrobenzene
and and few others cannot be
ionized with with electrospray ion
source
so it was assumed that all the
pesticides on the california list cannot
be
measured with lcms ms systems hemp
matrix is very challenging therefore it
causes ion suppression
and matrix in interference also
we needed to determine what should be
our sample preparation
for analysis of pesticides in different
hemp samples such as
plant concentrate and edibles to achieve
high throughput
to analyze all the pesticides on
california
list we used uh perkin elmer
q site lcm sms system with dual
esi and apci iron source
first i would like to cover the basics
of
ionization using electro spray and apci
ion source
i just want the listeners to remember
that with electrospray ios the
ionization takes place in liquid phase
and it is more suitable for analytes
with medium
to high polarity with apci ion source
ionization takes place in gas phase and
it is more suitable for
non-polar analytes so in order to extend
our method
to all the pesticides with different
polarities
and molecular weight we utilized
a novel dual esi apci source design
with different inlets so when
you are optimizing your ms method
you need to ensure that that you get
good sensitive with the difficult
analytes and one of these analytics
is named is abamectin ebermectin is a
pesticide
which has a very high molecular weight
and
and its ionization efficiency is very
low with
electrospray iron source not only it has
very low ionization efficiency it is
also
very sensitive to the heating in the
iron source
for most analytes if you increase the
temperature in the source
the signal would increase because of the
better desolation
but forever mechan when we increase the
temperature
the signal goes down by a factor of 10.
so after we did our temperature
optimization
to get the best signal fibromyactin now
we can
uh improve uh our signal for evomatine
by factor of 10
at a lower temperature and now we can
easily meet
uh california actual limits for mectin
with the electrospray ion source in our
system
also we measured these four
challenging analytes namely pcnb
chlorophenpi chloridaine and methyl
parathyon
using apci source these analytes are
very
nonpolar and hydrophobic and these
analytes have
either very little or no signal with
electrospray ion source
and that is why we are measuring these
analytes with the
apci iron source
this next slide essentially shows that
we get excellent signal to noise
for the these four challenging analytes
uh at california action limits of 100
ppp
in hemp uh using apci ion source
with our method we can meet uh
california action numbers of 100 ppb
in hemp because the loq for these
four analytes is in the range of 10 to
50 ppp
not only we can measure these four
analytes with
good sensitivity also our method
is very selective for analysis of these
analytes in hemp
so according to fda method valid
validation guidelines for
for a method to be selective it states
that
that the matrix blanks should not show
any
matrix interference peaks at the
retention time of the analyte
so in this slide essentially we are
showing
the signal from a hem blank and the
signal from
hemp spike with 10 ppb pcnb
so if you look at the red rays you can
see that
the counts for the hem blank are
less than 50 counts which is very low
and also it just shows random noise
it does not show any matrix interference
peak for pc and d
and also we show good
signal noise of about 23 at a very low
level of 10 ppb
for pcnb in hemp so this
slide shows clearly the analysis of pcnb
in hemp is both very selective
and sensitive using apci iron source
the matrix match calibration curve for
pcnb showed
excellent linearity over three and a
half orders of magnitude
with correlation coefficient of 0.9999
next i would like to talk about the
ionization mechanism of pcnb
with apci ion source so in this slide if
you look at the
structure of pcnb it has five chlorine
atoms
and one nitro group so for this reason
this molecule has
very very low proton affinity so it
cannot be ionized in
positive ion mode by protonating
this molecule most molecules form
m minus h minus sign in negative ion
mode by loss of a hydrogen ion
but if you look at the chemical
composition of pcnb
it does not even have a hydrogen atom so
therefore
it is not possible for this compound to
form m minus h minus ion
in apci ion source so
how did we ionize this compound
using apci ion source
so in this next slide what we are
showing here is our
postulated ionization mechanism of pcnb
with apci ion source we think that
the oxygen gas in the apci ion source
captures the electron formed in the
coronal discharge region of the source
to form the superoxide ions
and these superoxide reagent ions react
further with pcnb
to form an ion by loss of a chlorine
atom
and addition of oxygen atom
to provide a proof of this ionization
mechanism
we analyze the mass spectra of pcnb in
apci ion source
so first we we calculate the
monoisotopic mass of pcnb
which can be calculated easily by
knowing its chemical composition
and if we do the math the
mono isotopic mass of pcnb is
is 293 daltons
but if you look at the mass spectra in
the top part of the slide
the first isotope of pcnb
shows up at a nominal mass of 274
daltons so essentially
we are forming a pcnb iron in apci ion
source by loss of
19 daltons which can be calculated by
274 minus 293
so how can we explain this loss of 19
dalton
it can be easily explained by
our posterior ionization mechanism
because the mass of chlorine atom is 35
mass of oxygen atom is 16
so if you do a math again addition of
oxygen atom and loss of chlorine atom
means that
this will lead to a loss of 19 dalton
because 16 minus 35
is equal to minus 19. also
we compared the the isotope profile
of pcnb obtained experimentally in the
top part of the slide
with the theoretical isotope profile of
pcnb
with four chlorine atoms and you can see
it's a very good match
this shows further that when we ionize
pc and the apci ion source
we are losing one fluorine atom
also we studied the effect of mobile
phase composition
on both pcnb and superoxide ion response
so as we change our mobile phase from
one to two
we observed that the both pcnb and
superoxide ion response
increased substantially and this showed
further that
that superoxide ion plays a major role
in the ionization of pcnb in the
apci
next i would like to talk about matrix
interference
caused by hemp matrix for some
pesticides
so matrix interference is caused by uh
presence of isobaric compounds present
in the
hemp matrix as your pesticides
meticulous interference essentially
means that the matrix blanks show
peak for pesticides when the pesticides
are not present
in your hemp sample before i explain you
further how the matrix interference can
happen
i would like to explain you briefly the
theory of
lcmsms in lcms ms you inject
a sample containing your pesticides and
a hemp sample matrix on an lc column
lc column separates the pesticide
and hemp matrix in time as these
different pesticides and hemp
matrix compounds elude out of the column
they get introduced to
electrospray or apci ion source in these
ion sources
these compounds get ionized to form
either protonated molecular ion or
ammonia adapts
or both in positive one mode or
they can also form m minus h
minus ion in the negative ion mode
after the ions are formed they are
transferred to the
vacuum region of mass spec so in the
first vacuum region of
ms it isolates the
pesticides parent iron at fixed mass
these parent ions undergo further
fragmentation
in the collagen cell to form unique
product ions
and in the last part of the ms
it isolates and detects one of the
product ions
at the fixed mass so the matrix
interference can happen
when a hemp matrix compound has the same
elusion time parent time and product
iron as your pesticide
so in this next slide essentially i'm
trying to show here is that
if i try to use a conventional
m mass transitions for propynchronozole
uh in hemp what we see here in the top
part of the slide is that
we cannot differentiate between the
signal from a
hemp matrix and from a hemp matrix spike
with 100 ppp
so therefore it is very difficult to
meet california actual limits of 100 ppb
for this compound in hemp
but if i look at the bottom part of the
slide
and in which basically we are using
much more optimized mass transitions for
this pesticide propaganda result
we can minimize the matrix interference
signal which
is the net rays and now we can easily
meet
uh the california actual limits of 100
ppb
for this compound in hemp matrix
due to no matrix interface
next i would like to talk about the
sample preparation methods we can use
for extraction of pesticides from hemp
matrix so we could have used uh
any of these four sample preparation
methods
if you used quechu's dispersive solid
phase extraction and solid extraction
you will find that these methods are
very slow
difficult expensive and also show
poor recoveries for some of the
pesticide compounds
in comparison to these three sample
preparation techniques
sovereign extraction is fast quick
cheap and shows good recovery for
all the compounds therefore we believe
that solvent extraction is the best
sample
preparation method to achieve high
throughput in cannabis and hemp testing
labs for pesticide analysis
before i show you the
sample preparation recovery data
i would like to describe you
the formula for the sample preparation
recovery
it's essentially can be calculated by
taking a ratio
of the signal for an analyte in the
pre-spike extract
to the analyte signal in the post file
extract
in this slide the table shows excellent
recovery
for all the pesticides using
acetonitrile extraction
we get recoveries for all the pesticides
in the range of
80 to 120 percent with rst
less than 10
for comparison if we use sweatshirts
the recovery for demerizade would be low
since demonozite is a very polar
compound it has a very low
optimal water partition coefficient of
minus 1.5
therefore it will stay in the water
phase
during the salting out step of the
questions
if you used dispersive solid phase
extraction
or solid food extraction you would find
that
recovery for few more pesticides such as
pinocyte and few more
would be low lower than the acceptable
range of 80 to 120 percent
as i mentioned earlier a hemp matrix is
very
challenging and therefore we observed
ion separation for the signal of a
number of pesticides
in hemp matrix
a layman term ion separation means that
the
when the signal for your analyte in
sample is
uh less than uh the signal in your
solvent by 20
or more iron enhancement is observed
when the signal for your analyte in
sample
is greater than uh then the signal is
solvent by
20 or more for the most
analytes we observed ion suppression
from hemp matrix
for very few analytes we see ion
enhancement
and therefore during the rest of our
talk i would only
focus on ion separation effects from the
matrix at this stage
i would like to introduce another term
which is called overall recovery overall
recovery
depends both on your sample
preparation recovery and ion suppression
effects
so in this formula the first ratio
represents
the sample preparation recovery and the
second
ratio accounts for the ion suppression
effects
in next few slides i would like to show
you some approaches we took
to reduce the ion suppression effects
and
and compensate for it so the ion
separation effects
can be reduced by dilution of your
hem matrix but it will also reduce the
sensitivity of your method so in this
slide we are showing here is that
the signal for two pesticides in
solvent and in hemp matrix
diluted with acetonitrile with different
overall ratios
so if you see the the data for
carbofuran which is an early eluting
analyte
we can minimize the ion suppression
effects for carbofuran
by using a dilution factor of 10
for a late eluting analytes such as a
signified
the ion separation effects can only be
minimized by
dilution factor of 100x
so in order to
maximize our sensitivity and reduce the
ion suppression effects
uh as a compromise we are using a
dilution factor of
nx which is somewhere between one x and
hundred x dilution
this way uh we are uh reducing the ion
suppression
effects without compromising on the
sensitivity of the
early earthing analytes
also as i mentioned earlier due to the
iron suppression effects
the overall recovery is low
when you use solvent standard based
calibration
for quantification of pesticides in your
matrix
so from this graph you can see that if
you take the ratio
of the signal for asynchronicity in
pre-spiked hemp extract to a solvent
standard
the it shows you that over recovery is
very low which is about 33
due to the ion suppression
so how can we compensate for this ion
suppression to
improve the overall recovery
the answer to this question is that we
need to
use internal standards to our method
internal standards are important for
any method where we need to
you know improve the accuracy of your
quantification
so in this approach uh essentially we
are
adding a deuterated analog
of the analyte in a fixed amount to both
your solvent standard and your
hem sample in fixed amount
since this internal standard
has a structure as you analyte
it is expected that this internal
standard
will have same evolution time and
ionization efficiency
or iron suppression effects as your
analyte
so now if you take the response ratio
of your analyte to internal standard
in your solvent standard and in your
hemp extract
they would be quite similar and
now because of the addition of internal
standard
we can improve the overall recovery of
asic missile
from 33 percent to 87
in this slide the table shows the
overall recovery for different
pesticides as a function of retention
time
as it is well known that hemp matrix is
very
hydrophobic so it is expected that that
overall recovery for pesticides
will go down with increase in retention
time
and no internal standard but in our
method by
addition of a number of internal
standards we were
able to uh compensate for ion
suppression effects
uh with the addition of internal
standards to improve
the overall recovery of the late eluting
analytes
from the range of 30 to 70 percent to
acceptable range of 80 to 120 percent
also we participated in proficiency
testing
what is a proficiency testing
proficiency testing is an inter
laboratory test
in which different labor laboratories
participate in it
each lab is given a blank matrix sample
and an unknown spiked matrix sample
with different amounts of pesticides
and each lab is needs to determine the
amount of
pesticides in this unknown sample using
their method
if you pass this test it will assure a
good
quality of analysis that your lab to
your customers
if you do not pass this test it will
give you
an opportunity to assess and improve the
performance of your method
so when you get your proficiency test
report back
you need to look at the z-scores what is
the z-score
z-scores is calculated by taking an
absolute difference of your lab result
and mean of all the data and dividing
this number by
standard deviation of all the data if
the z-scores
are less than 2 that means your results
are satisfactory
and you pass the test if your z-scores
are between
2 and 3 that means your results are
questionable and you just pass the test
if your z-scores are greater than three
that means
your results are not acceptable and you
did not pass the test
and now you need to go back to the
drawing board and
determine ways to improve the
performance of your method
so we participated in emerald
scientific proficiency test for
66 pesticides in hemp and
i'm pleased to inform everyone that we
pass
this test with flying colors since
all the z-scores for
our method were less than two with no
false
positives and no false negatives and
also if you look at the z-score
distribution
with our method about 92
of the z-scores were less than 1.
this showed further that our method is
quite accurate for quantification of
66 pesticides in hand
in next three slides i would just like
to show you that
we can easily meet all the california
action limits for the pesticides in hemp
some of these pesticides are analyzed by
gcms ms
traditionally but we can analyze using
these pesticides using our novel method
with esi and apci iron source
and if you look at the last column of
this table
it shows you the ratio of the action
limits
to our to our method loq
so this number is greater than 2
this shows
quite clearly that we can easily meet
california action limits for
all the 66 pesticides in hemp
the second slide for this
set of three slides shows you again that
we can meet
california actual limits for these
pesticides in hand
and in this slide we are showing the
action limits for category one
pesticides in hand
and our method loq
so the main advantage of our of our
method is that now the customers only
need to use
one instrument one scientist
and one set of consumables to analyze
all the pesticides on california list in
hand
with the conventional methods you need
to use two instruments
gcms and lcms two scientists
and two sets of consumables to carry out
this analysis
with this i would like to state the main
points of my presentation we developed a
novel
lc-msms method with apci
and esi source which can meet california
action limits for
66 pesticides and hemp we elucidated the
mechanism of pcnb ionization with apci
and showed that the pcnb response is
selective and sensitive we can
minimize the matrix interference from
hemp
by optimizing the ms method we believe
that
solvent extraction is the most cost
effective sample preparation method
to achieve high throughput in cannabis
and hemp testing labs
we added a number of internal standards
to our method
which compensate for ion suppression to
get
overall recovery in the range of 80 to
120 percent
our method passed emerald proficiency
test for analysis of
66 pesticides in hemp
i would like to acknowledge a number of
my colleagues
at perky number and scientists at
different cannabis and hemp testing labs
such as napro
juniper and sc labs for their help in
generating some of this data and
discussions with them
i would like to thank the audience for
their attention and i would answer any
questions you might have